agents Natalia Sokolova has gone too far
using the countermeasure program
recovered from the attack on the Kansas
core she has disabled the White House's
defenses and attempted to retrieve her
lost asset btsu leader Barton Schaefer
her mission was thwarted by the heroic
sacrifice of former true son Captain
Fred Lewis
but the division had no time to
celebrate this win or mourn their friend
as the Black Tusk abducted several
members of the community who are
responsible for major services in DC
agent your mission is to recover our
missing people some of these assets may
be familiar faces and a few new people
who have helped you in the fight to save
what remains